abone ol
Selam merhaba iyi akşamlar
Ben neysem o ben ne dersem o değil ben
ne dersem o değil ama
Aslı inatla benim hiç sesin ne derse onu
hikayesi bu galiba çok güzel konuşmalar
dinledik Işık sebebiyle sizi göremiyorum
itiraf edeyim görebilmeyi Çok isterdim
insan iyi kendi bildiğini kendi
yaşadığını anlatabilir Ben de size kendi
gerçeğinden bahsedeceğim eksikleriyle
yapabildiklerini yapamadıklarımdan
Aslında uzaktan gelmedim güzellik
kilometre öteden geldim Trabzon
Akçaabat'tan geldim hikayenin başladığı
yer orası Bir Köy öğretmeninin çocuğuyum
Hüseyin öğretmenle terzi saadeti üç
çocuğunun en büyüğüm ben o ve ben Neysem
oyum işte o köyde doğan kız çocuğuyum
bugün bunu çok daha iyi anlıyorum
evinizin duvarında
bir tablo vardı benim yaş kuşağında
olanlar ya da işte büyüklerin evlerine
giden genç arkadaşlarım belki
görmüşlerdir O da etaminde işlenenler de
çok meşhurdur dönemde onun 3 çiçek
betimlenmiştir i3 tane gül ikisi açmış
bir daha Gonca ben erkek kardeşin
arasına girme ay var kız kardeşimde
dokuz buçuk yaş Annem babamdan ki bu
boncuğu olan en ucuz açmamış olan
Ayşegül en küçüğüz diğer açan varsa
Yücel'le sensin Biz hep böyle bilirdi ve
kafamızı bir köşesinde hala o Gonca olan
kız kardeşi koruma etkisi devam eder
kocaman bir insanlarımıza ailenin ne
kadar güçlü kavram olduğunu Geride
bıraktığım 56 yıllar Her gün bana daha
çok öğretti yaptığım her işte dedi Bu
sevgiyle şükrederek teşekkür ederek
anlıyorum ailemi Bu arada 56 yıl
aramızda kalacak bir şey söylemiyoruz
zaten geçmiş Dünya Sağlık örgütü'nden
iyice gayrım yok yani ben çok hoşuma
gitti o bir şafağa teşekkür ediyorum ve
bu üç kardeş O hiç çiçek kız kardeşim
onun büyüme dönemi çok net algılayacak
yaştayım o doğduğunda
önünde saçma işte fırçası tarak omzumda
masa örtüsü bir tane başörtüsüne bulursa
sürekli şarkılar söylerdi tek hayali
Müzikle uğraşmak the ve üniversite
sınavında Zaten normal sınav yetenek
sınavına odaklandım yerine gitmedi bile
ve müzik öğretmeni oldu eşiyle birlikte
bir dansimiz kokuları var çok güzel
öğrenciler yetiştiriyor ve çok mutlu
benim yerimde ise onun hayatını yolunu
çizen şeyler notaları oldu notaların
Peşine Düştü erkek kardeşim ve o
bambaşka O hala bana dünyanın temelinde
hayatın temelinde matematik olduğunu
anlatmaya çalışır Ben hala anlamamakta
ısrar ediyorum ısrar ediyorum gerçekten
anlatılır samimiyetle söylüyorum hocam
Fizikten bahsediyorsan hala ne demektir
kendimi zorluyorum anlayamıyorum yüzelim
evde yaptığı tek şey o dönemde kadar
Elektronik cihaz varsa elinizde işte
Radyo saat onları kurcalama açmak
kapamak nasıl çalıştıklarını incelemekte
sayılarla rakamlarla uğraşmakta onu
Dünyası sayılar üstüne kuruldu şimdi
sıfırla birileri de hayatımı yönlendiren
çok iyi bir yazılımcı O çok programları
imza atıyor ben kendimi bildim bileli
kelimelerin gücünü inandım kelimelerin
sihirli olduğunu düşündüler ve benim
evde sihirli Bir kutum vardı dünyaya
açılan pencereden bu değil yerindeyse
Trabzonlu küçük köyünde bütün dünyayı
oradan duyduğum seslerle Hayal ederdin o
cümleleri kimler kurar onca kelime
arasında en doğru kelimeleri kim seçer
yan yana getir bana bu kadar güzel
bilgiler aktarım içinden çıkamazdım
sabah dinlerdim okul saatini akşam
Tekrar dinledim gece gecenin içinde mi
dinlerdim o duyduğum seslere bedenler
giydirdim hayalimden o hikayeler içine
girmeye çalışıyordu Ve o kelimeler benim
ufkumu açtı da hala inanıyorum
kelimelerin gücüne kelimelerin büyüsün
eve Ben fark etmeden o kelimelerin
peşinden gittim aslında aynı kökten
beslenen aynı Sevgiyle büyüyen aynı
Cansu'yla oy kullanan o üç kardeş üç
farklı yola gitti Aslında anne babamız
Bizim kendi iç sesinizi duymamıza
müsaade etti o yüzden lütfen Elif
sesinizi dinleyin ve meraklarını zonları
not edin bir gün zamanı geldiğinde
karşınıza çıkacak onların size
sağladıkları mı o salyadan bahsettim Ya
ben işte o Radyo
hayal dünyamız zenginleştiren beni de
geliştiren bir unsuru Çünkü benim
çocukluğumun geçtiği dönemde bu kadar
çok kaynağa ulaşma şansımız yoktu şimdi
hayatımıza İnternet diye bir gerçek var
avucumuzun içinde bütün dünya istiyorsak
bize hizmet ediyor
bilirim hastalıklar arıyor ayrı konu
Tabii ki vb
o günün birinde benim bu merakım ın beni
Ankara Ankara'daki Sıhhiye'deki o tarihi
Binanın önüne götüreceğini O sitede onun
kapısından gideceğini ve seslerini duyup
hayranlık beslediği insanlarla yan yana
duracağı mı O noktaya getireceğini
bilemezsin O kapıya gittiğimde dizlerim
titremişti Aslında Berat uygun beni
TRT'nin Açmış olduğum sizi geldi
sınavına kadar
götürdüm televizyondan ilanı duydum
babam benim öğretmenim bu arada
Ben Hüseyin Öğretmen Benim ilkokul
öğretmenim Okulun bahçesine kadar
babacığım babacığım hala babacığım okul
bahçesine geçtikten sonra Günaydın
öğretmenim diye peşine takılıp gitmem
birlikte ilkokul biri kayıtsız okuyan 2.
sınıfta bir sınava girerek iki sınıftan
başlayan bir çocuğun üniversite bir de
16 yaşındaydım zekiymiş o zamanlar sonra
Bilmem bir şeyler oldu geldi ve
Radyo günlerinde Türkiye'nin ilk özel
radyosunda çalışan
insanından Radyo anki Ankara Büyükşehir
Belediyesi'nin kurduğu yayın merkezinin
ismi
bu daha öncesinde çocukluğunda bir bana
bu söyleseydi asla derdim Jülide Gülizar
Tuna hoş gibi rahmetle saygıyla anıyorum
O büyük ustalarla Birlikte çalışma
fırsatı buldu
daha sonra televizyon yıllardır 30 küsür
yıldır ekranında olduğun oooo bazı için
büyülü Bazıları için artık çok daha
keyifli olmayan Ala
bir öğretmen Ailesi için televizyon
ihtiyaçlar listesinde o dönemde pekte
öldürmeye çıkmayan bir unsur ama
çocuklar için o dönemde televizyon
Büyülü Bir dünya ve evlerinde televizyon
olsun istiyorlar bizim evimizde
televizyon yok komşunun evinde var ama
bizim için komşunun kapısını aile
olmadan gidip eve girip de televizyon
izlemek diye bir kavram yok yanlış bir
gün Saklambaç oynarken rahmetli komşumuz
Ayşe teyzenin evini perdesini açıyordum
Ben eski güzel Trabzon evlerinden biri
yaklaştım ve camdan içeri baktım merak
ediyorum Televizyon gündüz nasıl
görünüyor çünkü akşam da birkaç kere
aile git izlemiştim Ama gündüz nasıl bir
şey bir televizyon siyah beyaz dantel
örtü gördüm görmedi Ya Ayşe teyze
perdeyi kapattı Ben hala bu salınca
sıkıldı biraz Kızaran bir çocuğum ama o
zaman kıpkırmızı oldum ve ben daha eve
gitmeden benim Komşumun camına yapıştım
bilgisi aileye gittim Çok ayıp aile
Meclisi toplandı deyim yerindeyse ve
Borç harç elde bir televizyon alındı o
zaman nereden bilebilirdim ben ömrümün
neredeyse tamamını o ekranda çalışarak
geçireceğim ve işim Onun üzerinden
yürüyecek ve Ayşe Teyze de bir gün gelip
beni o ekrandan seyredecek diye
bu
ve bir başka nokta
da elimiz bir dönem oturduğumuz eviniz
söyle uyuma mıydı Ve böyle küçük odalı
bir yer yan tarafta altta köyün bakkalı
var eski bakkalları bilirsiniz
Karadeniz'de Ayrıca şarkı Koru kocaman
bir fazla ses ya Üzerinde o güzel
Trabzon ekmekleri dizili bir tarafta
horoz şekerleri ve o tahta tezgahı
köşesinde ekmekler kesiliyor gelene
veriliyor tezgahın altında da gazeteler
var eski gazeteler o zaman poşetler yok
Keşke şimdi doğmasa ve o eski gazeteleri
kesip kesip Mehmet Osman amcanın bakkalı
orası oldu Muhammed abi onları kese
kağıdı yapıyor Boş zamanlarında ya da
dörde büyük küçük şeylere sarıyor Ve
benim en büyük merakım Çünkü eve günlük
gazete ile her gün gelmez ilçe merkezine
gidip gitmediyse biri gazeteniz
alınmazdı hep eski gazete okuduğu zaman
ve gidip o tahta tezgahın altında
gazeteci okumaya bayılırdım
Ya ben gazetelerin en son manşetini
gördüm hala gazete sayfasına baktığımda
ilk görünen yeri neresidir marifetidir
ben en son maaşı görürüm Çünkü o eski
gazetelerde ve ortadan bölünmüştür ya
dörde önce köşedeki haberleri okuduk
haklarda Onlar tam haberler çoğunlukta
ya da sürmanşet bir haberin orta ve
doğru Haberin yarısı bulmaya başını
bulmam ya da sorunu bulunan bazen günler
sürerdi o sayfayı tamamladığında kendini
dünyanın en mutlu insanı zannederdi o
eski gazeteleri okurken ve birileri
gelip utanıp oradan çıkmaya çalışıp
kafamı tahta tezgahı vururken aklımın
ucundan bile geçmezdi bir gün bir
gazetede bir sayfa olacak İnci Ertuğrul
ve renkler diye bir sayfam olacak Orada
röportajlar yapacağım yazılar yazacağım
Gazete haberlerini okuduğum insanlarla
siyasilerle iş insanlarıyla işte
sanatçılarla röportajlar yapacağım diye
ama bu da oldu o Çünkü ben çocukken
içinden Bunları merak ettim bunları
istedim ve Aslında yolunu da ona göre
döşedim farkında olmadan
bu yolda döşerken tabi karşılaştığımız
insanlar çok önemli çok değerli ben şuna
inanıyorum hayatta hepimiz Birbirimizin
her öğretmeniz hem de öğrencisiyiz ve
hayatta öğrenme süreci son nefese kadar
zaten öğrenme ağzınızı bitirdiğimizde
kaybettiniz hayattan bir zevk
almıyorsunuz Bence Benim fikrim bu
karşılaşmalar çok değerli birbirimize
yapabileceklerimiz de var Yani bazen
durup dinlemek bazen gözümün içine bakıp
bir teselli etmek on sana dokunmak
sarılmak elinden tutup yürümek bir adres
göstermek bir ile tanıştırmak bir kitap
hediye etmek herhangi bir şey Her
birimizin bir başkası için yapabileceği
bir şey var hayatta ve Aslında bu küçük
mutluluklar bu küçük iyilikler
davranışlar bizi insan yapıyor ve bize
de mutlu yapıyor bizi mutluluk sebebimiz
Bunlar Ben TRT'nin spikerlik sınavı bir
merak duygusuyla girdim haddim olmayarak
bir gün bir program sunan bir sonucu ile
ilgili bir Bu bir söyleyiş ile ilgili
bir yorum yaptım böyle değil mi diye
neden böyle söylüyor dedi Babam dedi ki
eleştirmek kolay yapmak zordur kısmet
bu bilmediğiniz şeyler hakkında çok öyle
konuşmuyorum demek istedim ve bunu bu
merak duygusu ile sınava girdim O zaman
yazılı 1 sınav var ve Türkiye'de
televizyon yayıncılığı Ada Yayıncılık
trtek elinde yazılı sınavı geçtim bir
ses sınavına gittim ama hiçbir bilgim
yok Nasıl oluyor bu işler diye bir ses
sınavından çıktım ve radyonun
merdivenlerinden inerken Trabzon Radyosu
da arkamdan Bir de geldi bir abi koşa
koşa elinde kağıtlar var Bunları
anlatıyorum Her yerde benim için Çünkü
çok değerli bana uzattı dedi ki biz
burada bir iki arkadaşımız varsa
döneminizi yakın ileri beni valisinin
oğlu bir başka öğrencisi daha var onları
sınava hazırlıyorum vaktim olursa sen de
uğra ben baktım gidip gelme şansım yok
oraya O dediği günlerde o zaman dedi
bunları çalış baktım yok sayfaya
ve o harfi ile başlıyor Al bu
takatukaları takatukacıya
takatukalatmaya götür
benimle eğlenir herhalde dedim yani ben
sunuculuk spikerlik sınavına girdim ben
tekerleme ile ne işim olabilir
bunun Asem Berlin'de mücadele etmek için
çalışma yöntemlerinin başında geldi
bilgisi bile yok oldu tamam beğendi
bilgi ve tecrübe insanı yolunu
aydınlatan iki önemli Işık buna sahip
olanlara Lütfen bulduğunuzda böyle ya
kışın ve ne alabiliyorsanız alın buradan
Tufan abiye selamlar olsun Beni mesleğe
adım atmam da çok büyük bir rolü var
beni hiç tanımıyorum Benden hiçbir
çıkarı yoktu ama onun yüreğinde öğretme
aşkı vardı ve birisine bir şey
yapabileceğini düşünüyorsa ona destek
verme onu mutlu etmiştir
çok az önce daha cüzdan televizyondan
kelimelerin peşine düştüm den bahsettim
ya
Ama hayatımda en utandım anlardan birini
de anlatacağım size
o bir kere bir öğretmenimden cetvel yedi
hala şu ucum yanar Çünkü bir öğretmen
çocuğu olarak bunu yaşamış olmak benim
için çok büyük bir utanç the aileme bunu
nasıl izah eder diye sebebi bir kitap
bütün açlık kitabı yatıran bir çocuktum
Ben Ne kadar varsa ne kadar bir Tire
biliyorsan Kitap alırdım paramı kitap Ya
da dergi ders için bir kitap almamızı
istemiştim öğretmenim kitabın fiyatını
sorduk işte şu kadar da aşağı yukarı
dedi kitapçıya Gittim kitap söylenen
aynı tutarda para istedim ailemden Çünkü
bir şey biliyorum
gittim ve kitap 25 kuruş daha fazlaydı o
zaman
ve o kadar utangaç bir çocuktum ki ben
üniversite öğrenciliğim boyunca da bu
böyleydi onunla ilgili birkaç şey
anlatacağım ama saat kayboldu Ben
kontrol etmekte zorlanabilir kendimi
ve o kitapçıya benim param yetmiyor ya
da size getirdim demeye çekindim Oysaki
küçük bir yer ve mutlaka bana onu verir
yarın getir önemli değildi öğretmenime
de bunu söyleyemedim ve neden kitabı
almadım g cetvel avucuma indi
o gün bütün teneffüslerde tuvaletteydim
ağladım dersini çaldığında sınıfı en son
giren oldum ve Saklandım arkadaşlarımdan
ve sonrasında öyle senin durma öğrenci
gelip gönlümü almaya çalıştılar sesin
ama iş işten geçmişti ama bugün
bilemezdim bir gün bir kitap
çıkartacağım ıasa yazar demiyorum
kendime yazalım Ben henüz ve O kitapta
işte sessize konuşanlar sessizliğe sana
bu hikayeden de minik biçimde
bahsedeceğim i Hayat bizi öyle yerlerden
alıp öyle bir hale getiriyor ki biz
yeter Bu sürprizlere açık olalım ve
bunlara gönlümüzü açalım sonrası çok
daha kolay Çok da keyifle
Tabii ki zor zamanlar tabii ki sıkıntılı
zamanlar hepimizin yaşamında var ama
değişimler de var kendimiz eğitiyoruz
Çocukluğum büyük bir kızgınlıkla
geçmişti benim Karadeniz'de büyüyen bir
çocuk olarak Neden erkek değilim diye
çok kızardım Çünkü daha rahat yaşadım
daha özgür yaşamını istediğini
yapabilmenin yolunu
cinsiyetten geçtiğin zannederdim Ben
kadınların sıfırlandığını görürdüm
Kadınların haklarını teslim edilmediği
var bunun formülü olduğunu zannederdim
sonra anladım ki mesele insan olmakta
mesele birey olmakta ve belki de Bunca
zamandır ağırlıklı olarak Gündüz
kuşağında yer alan bir insanların
sıkıntılarını Özellikle kadın merkezi
sorunları işe şiddete maruz kalmış
çocukları anlatsam programlarda yer
almamın sebebi de belki de bu ama günün
sonunda şöyle dönüp baktığımda
Biz bunu son zamanlarda Farkediyorum 50
yılımı galiba kendilerini anlatmak
kaygısıyla yaşamışım hayatımın en büyüğü
böyle geçmiş kalanında çok ne yaptım o
bilgi senin çok farkında değildim zaten
Ama şimdi kendimi anlama sürecindeyim
ben Ben artık kendimi anlamı derdindeyim
bu demlenme dönemi ise
ve bu demlenme döneminde Bu arada da en
keyif aldığım şey o demli çayı içmektir
ve Çayı da mutlaka harmanlanmış çaydan
yaparım çünkü ben değişikliklerin
farklılıkların bizi zenginleştirdiği ne
inanırım iyi bir kaç çeşit çayı bir
araya getirip karışık bu şekilde
tomurcuk çekti böyle keyifle içerim onu
şimdi bu süreçte bütün hayatım boyunca
derdimi döktüm ağaçlar ve denizlerin
bana söylediklerini duymaya başladım son
dönemde bunu yapıyorum ben canım
sıkıldığında kolay kolay kimseye
anlatamazdım Bunu gider denizle
konuşurum birer ağaçlarla konuşurdum
Hatta benim kızım psikoloji okudu Dünkü
Anne bunun bir adı yok bildiğim
kadarıyla ağaçları bu kadar aşık olan
kimselerin ediyor Bu da aldı diye onun
üzerine doktora çalışması yapacağını
söylüyor nerede ama şimdi ağaçları ve
Denizi dinlemeye başladım onlar bana
konuşuyor artık Deniz bana diyor ki
Sen benden alınanı aradan yıllar geçti
da alırım Özellikle karadenizler bunu
çok iyi bilirler böyle denir burada ben
Çocukluğumda bu lafı ne anlama geldiğini
anlamıştım sonra yaşananlar da çok iyi
idrak ettim ve deniz bana gösteriyor ki
içine atılan ona ait olmayan maddeler
his likler ya da onu zorlayan durumlar O
konuşacak dalgalarla bir çıktı çıkıyor
Çünkü kendi içinde yaşar hale getirmeye
çalışıyor olmadı mı Kıyı atıyor ve
ağaçlar bana diyor ki biz yaprakları
mızı döksek de aslında daha güçlü
Hazırlanıyoruz Bahar gelecek yeniden
açacağız yeniden çiçek deneyeceğiz ve
bizim Gölgemiz de yine güzel yürekli
insanlar gelip oturacaklar bilirim
etraftakilerin sesini duyabilir herkes
çünkü biz tek başımıza
bu kadın ama farklılıklarımızla sahip
olduklarımızla paylaş bu kanımızla
öğrettiklerim izle
öğrendiklerimizle işte neysek oyuz O
yüzden lütfen hiç sesinizi dinleyin ve
herkesin de hiç sesini dinlemesine
müsaade edin Çok teşekkürler